[Musik]
meine fresse seerosen und damit herzlich
willkommen meine damen und herren wir
heute zu einem neuen blog auf meinem
kanal ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich
helga warum glaubst du eigentlich mal
wieder ich brauche geld
so einfach ist das mittlerweile schon
noch ein paar wochen keinen block mehr
gemacht deswegen erstmal hier hat sich
einiges verändert früher stand dieser
schreibtisch dort und der war voll mit
allen möglichen sachen jetzt habe ich
den staat sich allerdings über gestellt
mit meinem dj equipment und im
produktions equipment ihr habe ich jetzt
einiges nie verstehen warum ich aber
eigentlich primär den block holz gemacht
habe ist weil ich heute brennt
stadtbetriebs werden das ist allerdings
nicht der grund warum ich jetzt schon so
früh auf den beinen wind freundin als
der männerstimme die ist noch ein
bisschen tief ich bin ein bisschen
erkältet übelste pollenallergie wirklich
langweilig letzten tage mit ein paar
kollegen an der nordsee urlaub machen
und der urlaub bestand fast die ganze
zeit nur allerdings nicht der einzige
grund warum ich mir gedacht habe dass
ich euch mal diese kamera heraus kamen
sondern ich habe auch das shooting für
die neuen klamotten am ersten sechs da
heißt es
in dem krieg ich gehe jetzt erstmal
duschen und dann fahren wir zu dem
shooting
lassen sich zum shooting auf zum
shooting auch zum shooting das übrigens
auch nicht debattiert und shooting bei
vista das thema so grimassen bei dem
bilder machen für den shop uns na ja zum
ersten mal die finale jeansjacke
wenn jetzt das shooting beendet meine
damen und herren es war auf jeden fall
gaz soll ich hab fordert jubel einfach
gemacht
[Musik]
wir haben auf jeden fall beide den tod
des hunger bestellt ist das schon was zu
essen damit wenn wir nach hause kommen
das heißt quasi direkt da ist und da ja
dumm
ihr fragt euch vielleicht halo karstadt
gesagt hat jetzt nach haus und das habe
ich auch gedacht doch dann waren wir zu
hause in meiner wohnung und ich dachte
hey ich meine kamera im auto vergessen
von 3 konnte er zwar nichts ähnlich wie
nudeln gegessen haben das waren aber
noch ein zwei stündchen die wir zu hause
waren ich habe mein video fertig gemacht
was ihr quasi dann gestern gesehen habt
also wo ich die neuen klamotten
vorgestellt habe
und wir fahren jetzt nach düsseldorf zu
carola und dann gehen wir wollen
hauptsache willkommen düsseldorf an weil
und das ist einfach völlig antiquierte
die körperlose purer sonnenschein
angekommen bei carola hier werden wir
auch wohl noch in dem kleinsten menschen
gewählt wir kennen und freuen wenn man
draußen schaut
ich weiß immer das sieht hier vorne
vielleicht ist es zu krank um schütten
wir waren jetzt gar noch kurz bei carola
einfach weil wir saras ausweis haben
weil sie tatsächlich darauf fest nicht
mitgenommen düsseldorf ja auf jeden fall
müssen jetzt gucken dass er sarah da
irgendwie rein kriegen ohne auswärts
geht das eigentlich nicht aber auf kurs
denn sie der germany's next topmodel ich
werde das ist ja angekommen ist die
arena sieht aus wie ein ufo grad noch
immer kein auslauf mit wie fühlst du
dich bist dann instagram burschen
instagram san luca
jeder mensch hat hier so rum mit kleid
oder mit anflug sowie johannes da vorne
und ich habe einfach ein normaler
johannes r
ja ich bin noch eine dame johanna ist
ganz kurz wie ein kleines problem
sorry aber was denkt sich solche leute
da oben wollt ihr von da in die arena
ein gruppen- oder lassen das sind
übrigens die leute damit wie bitte
[Musik]
wir sind auf unseren plätzen dass die
arena und nehme nicht
[Musik]
hallo
was sich übrigens im video gestern nicht
gesagt aber damit meine
die neuen klamotten vorgestellt was ich
allerdings vergessen habe zusagen sind
auch drei kurze sachen und zwar erstens
haben jetzt auch ein shopsystem also
zuerst magento 2 ist das krasseste
es gibt also wir können nicht mehr
irgendwie direkt werden oder die server
können nicht mehr darum gehen und
zweitens ich werde wieder 1000 sticker
signieren das heißt wenn ihr am ersten
sechs in einer woche
zu dem was bestellt bekommt ihr
einstiger wenn halter von den ersten
1000 seiten komplett neues design also
der die viel cooler aus und jetzt warten
wir mal bis das handy losgehen
20 jahre später ist haben wir die
losgegangen aber wir haben patchwork
drei wochen später die drei leute aus
der teenager und hi hat irgendwie kommt
ich weiß nicht ob das die falsche
sendung ist aber die sieht aus wie ein
gespenst altherr freunde jetzt keinen
scheiß großen
das ist nicht mein gott da vorne werden
gerade die highlights der letzten
sendungen
wenn ich hier bei ihrem viertel oder bei
sauberer
die steine klopfen hat so unterstützen
dort können sich dann beweisen sie
laufen nicht besser
hier sollen es eilig die feiert die
ganze nämlich ein bisschen anderen
[Musik]
ein alkoholiker hier vorne mit ihrem
bier und habe mich stets fair verhalten
er war auf dem stundenbuch halter waren
duschvorhang mit den beiden länder ist
meine damen und herren einzige was kann
die eine hier vorne hat einfach einen
gipfelsturm auf dem kopf ich freue mich
mittlerweile nichts mehr laut ja mit
cara täglichen verhinderte das umfasst
bei glauben schild übrigens und pander
[Applaus]
gerade ist die entscheidung freunde
wieder aus
[Applaus]
juan arango
slater
[Musik]
ja das ganze ist jetzt hier vorbei wir
sind jetzt draußen kann es auch zur
after show an der stelle noch mal ein
ganz ganz großen glück von tobi die
antoni die ihr gewonnen hat es war
wirklich eine sehr sehr sehr sehr krasse
show danke schön an prosieben dass du da
sein dürfte war echt sehr cool und ja
nein ja die coolsten hinten sehr
vorsichtig scheine sei nämlich nicht
immer dann müsste eigentlich luc godard
ausstehenden freunde das haus wundervoll
ich gebe jetzt seine kamera das essen
ist aus haben sie mit dem iphone
hier sei wieder besser lieblings blogger
ich habe natürlich nichts mehr auf der
aftershow gefilmt und wir jetzt auch
bereichen schnell erkennen können bin
ich zu hause bei meiner familie also wir
haben beide carola gepennt in düsseldorf
wollte schon der nächste tag ich bin
nach hause gefahren zu meiner familie
hier weil's 30 grad
da will ich nicht in köln in meiner
wohnung sterben und verrecken sterben
und verrecken weil ich dabei dass ich
wollte allerdings nicht nehmen lassen
noch mal hier so ein kleines fazit zu
ziehen für diese ganze sache also man
muss erst mal sagen das klein-klein
wahrscheinlich kleine klum oder paris
aus wird war irgendwie so eine mischung
aus spaghetti und shetland pony aber das
hat ja nichts mit der chance tun die ich
meiner meinung nach sehr sehr cool fand
ich habe richtig gelesen von spiegel
beispielsweise wo sie meinten die schau
waren echt nicht so gut
claudia mit car wurde bei ihrer räder
unterbrochen der personell
person vergeben weil sie die meisten
follower hat und das halten sogar in der
rede gesagt er hat gesagt es ist ein
sehr buntes finale und das einfach nur
weil da bei etwas dunkelhäutige menschen
wahl und ja also ich habe vieles
negatives gelesen ich muss allerdings an
der stelle ganz kurz sagen dass ich
eigentlich echt ganz cool fanden war bei
so etwas dabeizusein also bisher war ich
bei solchen live shows halt wirklich
immer nur dabei wird wie es
beispielsweise bei bg dagegen gewinner
oder damals bei der völker bei
meisterschaft auf prosieben die beiden
sendungen so wirklich als teilnehmer und
dann ist es halt noch mal ganz anders
wirklich im publikum zu sitzen deswegen
fand ich es mega cool dass prosieben uns
da eingeladen hatte also ihr seht ihr
auch nicht vom werbevideo ich bekomme
kein geld oder irgendwie so weit
gekommen
die tickets bekommen und es war auf
jeden fall cool das ganze war zu sehen
ist war ich fand es waren sehr sehr
cooles event ms wappen gemacht weil die
lichttechnik und so das war schon echt
krass das war echt heftig ich würde der
stelle den blog jetzt allerdings auch
beendet ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
ich hoffe ihr fand es lustig wenn das
der fall war das gerne mal ein
weiterschreiben kommentar ob ich
eventuell demnächst öfter mal wieder
flocken soll und jetzt
[Musik]